remember the scene from Blues Brothers
where Elwood tells his brother Jake that
their new ride was running a 440
cubic-inch top power plant the cap tires
top suspension cap shocks
that's over 40 years and every cop car
out there is still pushing a v8 engine
until now Ford's new Police Interceptor
puts out 66% more power with an Joliet
Jake Bluesmobile by bolting on a couple
of turbochargers and it's only of these
six in fact it's the quickest cop car
out there doing zero to sixty and five
point six six seconds
but not all about speed and efficiency
remember a criminal shoot at these cars
the Interceptor uses body armor capable
of stopping and pistol or rifle round up
to a 7.62 millimeter Full Metal Jacket
and the company has developed software
using a rear-view camera that alerts the
car to any bad guys creeping up from
behind if it sees you it will
automatically roll up the windows lock
the car and sound the alarm
of course most officers would rather not
get jumped or shot at and to help
eliminate those risky runarounds a
company called Starr Chase has developed
a cannon that shoots a GPS tracker at
speeding scofflaws rubber from the
tractor sticks to the car and leads the
police straight to de fuga t'v no
high-speed chase necessary to all police
forces around the country upgrade to a
new interceptor outlaws on the lam
better think of a new way to get a leg
up
you